الخلافات بين الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
وخصميه الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني تتجه نحو
تصعيد اشد سياسيا وامنيا في اقليم كردستان
العراق في غياب تاما لوساطا ما يجعل الوضع
يسير نحو صراع مفتوح دفع ببعض الاكراد
للقول انه تهديد وجودي للاقليم الذي يتمتع
بحكم ذاتي ملفات كثيره عالقه بين الحزبين
الرئيسيين ابرزها الانتخابات البرلمانيه
في الاقليم التي تهدد بتصعيد الصراع داخل
البيت الكردي منها كيفيه الوصول الى قانون
الانتخابات يضمن تكافؤ الفرص المشاركه
الحقيقيه وتحديث سجل الناخبين وكل ما
يتعلق بالمكونات الاخرى وايضا ما يخص
المفوضيه العليا المستقله للانتخابات في
الاقليم
فقط بسبب المؤتمر بل عدم انتخاب الدكتور
برهام صالح رئيسا للجمهوريه كان سببا في
هذه الخلافات او تطور هذه الخلافات ان كان
هناك تط للخلافه كانت هناك شده بسبب شده
الخطاب الاعلامي من الاتحاد الوطني اتجاه
الحزب الديمقراطي فهذا بسبب الانتقادات
التي وجهت للاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني
لا تخص شقه الانتخابات فحسب بل تشمل
الطاقه وانعكاسها على حياه المواطن الكردي
وملف المال والخلاف على توزيع الثروات
والايرادات في اقليم كردستان على جميع
المحافظات
متعدده كثيرا هناك مختلفه الاتحاد يختلف
عن وجهه نظري عن الحزب الديمقرا
لكوريستاني لما يتعلق بقضيه اداره الحكم
نحن نبحث عن نقاط مختلفه عن ما يبحث عن
حزب الديمقرا لكن بالتالي الاتحاد يبحث عن
تواصل ويبحث عن نقاط ايجابيه ويجب ان
لاستثمار بعض الملفات الصغيره التي تجزء
البيت الكردي على الاصطدام بين القوتين
السياسيتين يخص ايضا موضوع ورقه عمل
مشتركه مع الورقه الاتحاديه تتعلق بجميع
الملفات التي تهمه اقليم كردستان العراق
والملف الاتحادي فضلا عن الخلافات حول
الامن والحدود والنفط مع بغداد والتي
اوصلت التوتر بينهما لصدام محتمل
بلال البوجديني العربيه